on voit là en distribuant les gilets qu'
il ya un certain nombre d'usagers qui
connaissent la vélostation et pour
certains qu'ils utilisent
je discutais avec le gestionnaire de la
vélostation qui m'expliquait que il ya
des réparations qui se font là et qui
sont programmés jusqu'au mois d'août
donc grand succès ça répond à un vrai
besoin sur de la population donc c'est
un très très bel outil offert aux
habitants de montigné de 50 à la
vélostation se divise en 3 trois
divisions
la première consiste à louer des vélos
de vélos de ville de vélo de en location
la deuxième donc qui consiste à allouer
des places de parking sécurisé donc des
places de consignes et la troisième un
pôle réparation de vélos